joining me today is the president of the
Herzl Institute in Jerusalem the
director of the John Templeton
Foundation project in Jewish
philosophical theology and the author of
several books including the virtue of
nationalism
Yamaha's Oni welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me it's great to be
here I am glad to have you here because
as I said to you in the green room just
a moment ago you're one of about 12
people that I see on Twitter that
doesn't completely enrage me you
actually make a little bit of sense on
that Twitter machine that's the highest
compliment I could possibly pay any that
that's a pretty serious compliment and I
don't know how many people would agree
with you but I'm glad finally to meet
with that background that's that that's
wonderful thank you yeah so okay so
before we get into the book and it's
called the virtue of nationalism and
just even just saying the word
nationalism sort of sets bells off for a
lot of people so we're gonna we're gonna
kind of quantify and qualify what that
word actually means you were born in
Israel you live in Jerusalem now tell me
a little bit about your background well
in between the being born in Israel and
living in Jerusalem I actually you can
you can hear the my on your American
accent yeah so I grew up in in Princeton
New Jersey and what went to school there
met my wife there did a doctorate at
Rutgers and nearby and putting in
political theory and and then Julie and
I moved to Israel we I worked for a
while for Netanyahu for a few years
quite a while ago already and then set
up a conservative think tank called the
shell M Center which did about 20 years
of work trying to figure out what
Israeli and Jewish conservatism would
would be like we have nine kids and
which is probably the the the biggest
achievement and I've been kind of pulled
back you've noticed in the last few
years pulled back into American and
European issues because you know for
most of my life I felt like Israel was
the front lines and that
you know that that's where I was really
needed and these days like for the first
time in my life I feel that you know I'm
America and Europe are actually kind of
in worse shape than Israel is so yeah
what do you mean by that
how was Israel at the front lines where
that's now shifted
well Israel used to be a I mean it still
is to an extent a strong and I'm sorry
it's a small and struggling country in
in a sense like it the the edge between
the the order of the Western world and
kind of kind of chaotic bedlam and
needed a little need a lot of help in
order to strengthen itself America
looked fine for most of that time and
today I think the situation is almost
flipped where Israel is the strongest
that it's ever been and in a lot of ways
as defeated many of its of the problems
the dog did in the last generation and
and America's fraying and and the UK is
fraying and you know I don't have to
tell you I mean it's not like Israel is
is is going to do well if if you know
the entire West kind of disintegrates so
so I've spent the the last few years and
that that's how we know each other
through desert through through Twitter
and and writings that are directed in
trying to to help America in the UK and
other other Western countries with the
issues that I think are facing them now
yeah so we're gonna spend most of the
interview obviously talking about those
issues but nine kids living in Jerusalem
what's living in Jerusalem like I feel
like it's probably maybe not probably
maybe maybe exactly the most
misunderstood place on planet earth for
good reason
oh gosh I mean it's it's in some ways
it's just a dream you know I mean well I
I walk on Friday night with my we have
twin twin 10 year olds and I walk with
them to synagogue we walk down the hill
to synagogue and
and you can see the whole city from from
where we are because it's kind of on a
hill and and you know for a Jew it's um
it's really kind of a miracle that after
a couple of thousand years in which my
my ancestors were were praying please
God bring us back so that one day we'll
be able to you know to see the the Jews
return to Jerusalem and we actually get
to see it so it's it's incredibly moving
and it never loses its its magic but you
know on the other hand it's also you
know it's also a very real place and in
in a very real political location and
today everything is basically you know
quiet and peaceful in Jerusalem pretty
much all the time but you know just if
you go go go back just to the mid-2000s
we had a period where there were
literally bombs going off in the cafes
and the buses of the city every day and
and when Israel invaded Bethlehem to put
in an end to this my wife and I then we
were living on the southern part of the
city and you know we walked hand-in-hand
up to a hill from which we could see the
the Israeli armor entering the city and
the the tanks shooting and I mean it's
like what you see on television except
we just sat there and watched it with it
with our own eyes so you know we had six
months at that time in which we had
helicopter helicopters patrolling over
our house every night and and and so
it's both things it's both the it it's
both the front lines of civilization and
and you can feel the fragility of you
know what we've built we can you can
feel that it's fragile and and know that
nothing is certain about what's going to
happen next on the one hand on the other
hand it you know on a daily basis you're
connecting to a history of thousands of
years
- you know biblical hopes and
aspirations that you know that for for
people in in America it's mostly
schoolbooks but for you know the things
that you you learn as a kid in in in
school or in Sunday school or someplace
but or you hear from your grandparents
but here we're really doing it we're
really recreating a Jewish country after
thousands of years so it's it's the
highs and the lows and it's an
extraordinary life do you think in a
weird way that the the threat of
bombings or terrorism or whatever else
is going on or the general seemingly
existential threat because it's such a
small country actually helps the
ingenuity that comes out Israel because
I remember I was there a few years ago
during the stabbing sprees and I went
right into the old city of Jerusalem and
you know my mom was texting me you know
you don't have to go there and I just
went right in and I remembered there was
a certain tension you know it was kind
of looking around but I went into the
Arab quarter and I walked through the
gate and somebody had just been stabbed
there the day before and I thought you
just you just have to keep going if
people can live like this I can
certainly do it for one day of my life
for a couple hours of my life yeah I I
first of all I'm real pleased that you
did that you know a lot of people just
get scared and and and and you know
seeing something seeing something on
television seing some violence and then
deciding you're gonna let live your life
you're gonna decide where you're gonna
go and and what you're gonna do and what
you're gonna say because because you saw
something on TV and got scared yeah I I
mean I understand it but but I don't
think it's the best way to live and well
you can also see that these people live
on top of each other these quarters are
right on top of each other and I had
kunafa in the Arab quarter and I had
falafel in the Jewish quarter and
everyone's existing and not killing each
other I mean I think the truth right
they they they do but our you know our
future depends on on you know countless
little acts of you know of bravery like
that like I'm not going to be deterred
I'm gonna go eat I'm gonna go eat that
fluff I'm gonna lead a normal life here
that's what builds the normal life is
people like you saying that so it's
there really is a daily effort which
which is built on countless small acts
of of bravery and there's a Talmudic
famous Talmudic saying how it's in the
cadets be Salim that the the land is
only one through hardship and these are
little tiny hardships that you know sons
of some some something scared you
something feels feel feels uncomfortable
but you're gonna do the right thing
anyway it's good it's it it it's good to
live that way it's good to live not
afraid well said
all right so let's talk about
nationalism because as I said if you
just say the word nationalism or if you
say I'm a nationalist or anything like
that the connotations or the
implications are that you're somehow
racist you're xenophobic all of these
things so first off can you just define
at least in your view what nationalism
is sure I actually I I grew up in a
nationalist house you know meaning like
like many Israelis do and it's not just
Israelis people in India people in
Ireland there's a lot of countries in
the world where where people still
remember that a national movement is is
a struggle against Empire and so it's a
struggle for for freedom and and and it
still has good connotations so in in
those kinds of traditions which I draw
on in in my book nationalism is
understood to be a principled standpoint
that sees the world as governed best
when it consists of many independent
nations so each each nation will have it
its own laws its own traditions its own
language and religious customs and will
live independently without being forced
to live a certain way by by by by other
nations by right and this is this is
basically how we view
world for the last hundred years or so
right I mean most relatively sane people
that there are countries and they have
borders and there are Indiana go she ate
together right but it's it but but but
it's not it's an this way of viewing the
world is about three or four hundred
years old in its current version in in
the book I actually argue that that that
this is a biblical ideal right you don't
find the the Greeks of the Romans
painting a picture of a world of
independent nations that that vision of
a world of independent nations is a is
something that inherits I'm sorry that
that enters our inheritance from from
Hebrew Bible and then it appears
throughout you know throughout Western
history and various forms and in in
various parts of Christian and Christian
history so in its current form that the
the feeling of a just world a free world
is one of competition among independent
peoples it's about depending on how you
count it's about three or four hundred
years old the first the first country in
Europe to to to explicitly declare
independence is is England in 1534 Henry
and Andrew the 8th says we're not even
formally going to be part of the Holy
Roman Empire anymore we're just we're
just independent we're doing our own
thing and that that model was picked up
by by the Dutch by the Scots by the
Swiss by the French by various others
and and then becomes kind of the basis
for a an ordering of the world where
this became more and more the intuition
of course the work plenty of you know
plenty of empires during those times and
lots of injustice and and I don't want
to turn it into like some kind of it you
know utopia or something it wasn't but
slowly the the idea that there's
something good about allowing nations to
to go their own way and to be free that
that did become the common the common
sense view and still was up until up
until World War two I think it was
really only in the 1960s that that
academics and Intel
Jules really turned against against this
idea and began arguing that nationalism
is just you know it's just an evil right
so what shifted then in the 1960s
because when you talk about nations with
borders that can decide what they do
within their borders and that people can
have a nationalism that they can be
proud of that isn't xenophobic or racist
or the rest of it I think that makes
sense to most people right I it is you
said common sense it strikes me as
common sense so what happened in the 60s
was that sort of a latent period after
world war two that these ideas bubble
yeah it it's it's all about the trauma
of World War one in World War two it
it's all about that and the beginning
immediately after World War two there
were Marxists and there were liberals
who said look Hitler's a nationalist and
it's true that Hitler called himself a
nationalist I mean they Hitler called
himself a nationalist but he's actually
an imperialist because from the very
beginning his goal was not for Germany
to you know to be independent his goal
was for Germany to become as he said
Lord of the earth mistress of the globe
so Hitler's not not you know our
traditional idea of a national right so
that's his understanding of rationalism
right there right because if he had been
a just if he had been a nationalist by
the strict definition then he wouldn't
have wanted to do anything outside right
so so he would have been terrible for
Germany but not necessarily starting
world war with France and England and
Russia and everybody else but it would
have been terrible for Germany anyway
but but you can't call him a nationalist
according to my tradition if his dream
his aspiration is not the freedom of his
people his dream you know among other
peoples his aspiration is to is to rule
the globe right was expanding right okay
so so imperialism versus nationalism
that that's four people are nationalists
instead of critics of national for
people are nationalists that that's the
big divide is are you looking are you
willing to give the respect of
self-determination to men
like your own or are you really just
looking to conquer the world so after
world war ii various anti-nationalist
theories that hadn't succeeded in in
getting traction up until then got a
huge boost from the fact that that
Hitler was a National Socialist and and
and that when he spoke about imperialism
used the word nationalism and and the
the academic intellectual culture let's
say it was still still producing defense
of nationalism against imperialism still
through the 1950s but by the time you
get to the 1960s
you get Elie Kaduri is a famous Pro
imperialist scholar who wrote a book
called nationalism which is kind of an
anti nationalist manifesto that blames
nationalism for both world wars and and
says it's on it's unworkable offer all
of the arguments that that are familiar
to people today are already in kaduri's
work that that the divisions among
peoples by creating independent states
you create borders borders are always
something people argue about that itself
produces Wars and triggers Wars and and
and then the the thinking that your
country is great right making your
nation great again that kind of stuff
that it the argument is that that kind
of nationalism necessarily produces
hatred and hatred violence war
intolerance it kind of takes all of the
you know the worst things of recent
centuries in the past and pins it on on
this this one word in this one idea so
if that's not the case how did these
ideas then pick up is this just sort of
where we see this now in academia where
they just sort of pick ideas that they
sort of all agree on are true and then
it just runs throughout the universities
and then event
in the media yeah and then it gets
broadcast the universities are are a
hothouse for the development of ideas
which is you know in principle is a
really really wonderful to be good right
in principle that's a really wonderful
thing but because academia is
overwhelmingly I mean you know consists
of a debate between kind of neo-marxists
who want to you know whose was aim is to
achieve justice by undermining pretty
much all inherited ideas one after
another that so there's that and then
there's there's the great majority of
academics who are who are liberals and
and don't necessarily you know agree
with the neo-marxist um but it turns out
that they're not very good at at at
resisting it so academia ends up being a
fight between two Universalist visions
and they're both utopian one is a
neo-marxist Universalist vision which is
utopian and the other is a liberal
Universalist vision rich is utopian and
ideas that are like nationalism with our
particular estar arguing for the the
goodness of the justice of of defending
your own people looking out for their
interests their tradition their culture
that kind of thing
violates the universalism of both the
Marxists and the Liberals right so have
we watched sort of the failure of
liberalism here so if the neo-marxists
and the post modernist even if they're a
smaller percentage at the universities
then the Liberals that the Liberals
somehow I mean this is what I've been
trying to noodle through for the last
couple of years now that the Liberals
somehow didn't have enough to stand on
to stop the bad ideas of the neo-marxist
yeah exactly you and you and you can you
can actually see why because because the
the neo-marxists have have I mean the
the the agenda valves and it develops
but but it's always a you know very
clear picking out picking
of ideas that need to be destroyed and
uprooted picking out of you know the
institutions that need to be destroyed
and uprooted they're constantly saying
to get justice then you know we need to
overthrow this that and the other thing
and the Liberals their response is no
everybody just should be free to do
whatever they want and you know of
course I'm pretty sympathetic to that
but but what you say it's not enough
it's not it's not enough when that's the
contest one side is saying here's a
really clear agenda for for what we got
to do in order to fix the problems in
the world and the Liberals are always
someone for another of saying well no
let's just everybody leave everybody
should do whatever they want and that
that's not good enough if you if you're
fighting a strong vision of you know
what would be right you need an you need
to counter it with a strong vision or
you'll lose yeah and that's what happens
I mean that's what I'm seeing right now
with with the Liberals in the United
States it's like this this ever
dissipating group of people that are
sort of standing on quicksand because
the left the neo-marxists have sort of
taken over the Democratic Party and all
the apparatus of the left and then you
have liberals who now mostly secretly
agree with conservatives in a lot of
ways right but they can't but they're
afraid to say that and then they're
they're just we're just watching them
whittle away it's it's it's sad to me in
many ways for the ideas that I care most
about well we don't know how it's gonna
don't get too sad you know we're really
bad at predicting yeah what's gonna
what's gonna happen if people are just
bad at it so we got to figure out what's
worth fighting for and we may win we may
lose but you know it's it's a mistake to
think that we know how it's all going to
turn out we we just don't right nobody
well if we knew I wouldn't be doing this
I nobody predicted the the the collapse
of the Soviet Union are almost nobody
and nobody predicted the the rise of
brexit and Trump and nationalism now or
the code that the housing bubble we're
just we're terrible at at seeing the
future what we got to do is we've we've
got to think strategically about what
kinds of ideas are out there and what's
needed and we need to work to build up
an alternative framework
it's gonna be more conservative and more
attractive and and and and and and
capable of rallying people which which I
think liberalism is is less and less
capable of doing these days so and I've
seen you do some Twitter threads on this
sort of thought so I obviously want to
talk about Trump and brexit and how they
fit into this conversation but so if if
liberalism has a certain faulty what are
the answers that conservatism has that
you would say could stop some of the
rise of this new work is that
conservatism the word conservatism
refers to two different political
movements which are which are
traditionally based their traditionalist
so conservatism is not it's it's not a
universal theory so it's it's not like
Marxism or liberalism where you take a
Marxist or a liberal and they'll tell
you how the whole world should think you
know in all times in all ages every
place in the world conservatism is not
like that because it means because being
a traditionalist means you know I'm a
I'm a respect more or less the
traditions of of the Russians or the
Chinese or the the the Indians or the
Germans but but all those trigger each
each one of them is different right so
so I some of them are like more and some
of them like less in in the American
context or let's say the anglo-american
context to be a conservative means a
specific thing it means to be to believe
that the anglo-american political
traditions political and religious
traditions are a an extraordinary
achievement that they they are one of
the the the the greatest if not the
greatest one of the greatest traditions
that have ever been developed in
mankind's history and that most of what
we value in in them what we love about
the modern world whether it's the the
the idea of limited government or
individual liberties or
or the the the kind of science that that
grows out of out of Newton or the kind
of culture that grows out of you know
common-sense skepticism all of these
things they're part of the
anglo-american inheritance of an
empiricist attitude towards knowledge a
common law tradition tradition which is
not based on on universal rights but but
which pioneered freedom of speech and
freedom of of property in fact most of
over what's in the American Bill of
Rights is these traditional English
English rights which were not developed
by liberals they were developed by
conservatives fighting against against
the authoritarianism of let's say the
Stuart's so when we talk about
conservatism we're not talking about
there's one set of ideas that are
eternally always true we're talking
about a tradition of a certain nation or
group of Nations which by trial and
error
right so it's empirical right by trial
and error over over centuries over
thousands of years in fact have
succeeded in developing and said is
stumbling upon things that are just
spectacular and that are kind of a gift
to to the rest of mankind and today what
what what we're seeing is that the
educational institution is rather than
saying look let's take a look at the
traditions of this nation and and you
know the thousands of years of
development going all the way back to
the Bible let's see how it contributed
to the things that that we care about
that that's what a conservative would do
and say what contributed to to the
things we care about and how can we
strengthen those strands in the
tradition both nationally and also in
our in in our personal lives how can we
live as conservative people who will
raise children to respect the things
that should be respected that
what conservatives focus on and so their
Klingon conservatives are always playing
a completely different game from from
liberals liberals are trying to try to
tell you some abstract set of rules that
if everybody were to follow them then
everything would be great and
conservatives say there is no such
abstract set of rules that if everybody
followed them everything would be great
what there is is nations handing down a
way of life which have some good things
about them some bad things about them
but but everything that's good about
them is coming down from that tradition
so we need to be working on
strengthening it and and and and and and
and improving it so as we're watching
what I would say is sort of the collapse
of liberalism on the left and now
there's sort of all of these refugees
many of whom have been in this very
studio and who watch this show that
there are refugees that I think are
moving to something that is center-right
which I see is rich with ideas and
debate and all of these things I think a
lot of people have some fear if you've
come from the left they have some fear
that there's some sort of religious
connotation attached to conservatism now
you just explained a little bit of the
history of that but do you think there's
room for a secular conservatism can that
can that fit within there okay it's a
great question and and there's no
there's no simple answer to it because I
let me say something one thing that's
really simple you don't have to become
an Orthodox Christian or an Orthodox Jew
in order to take part in in this great
inheritance which is your inheritance
okay that's it it's a different question
to say is it actually possible to
sanitize it of all religious aspects
that I'm more doubtful so let's take
taken an example that's really related
to this book I mentioned earlier that
the the the idea of national
independence is a biblical idea the the
Romans didn't believe in national
independence the Greeks didn't believe
in national independence I mean it it it
has a source and its source is
in in this tradition that says that you
know God of Israel God if God creator of
heaven and earth is speaking to Moses
and unlike all the other gods of the
ancient Middle East this particular God
does not order his people to go out and
conquer the four corners of the earth
which is what the gods of the Assyrians
and the Babylonians were doing God if
that's a pretty big sea change from what
was happening before that it's an it's
an incredible I mean that in in in at a
certain level that's what that's what
the Hebrew Bible is about it's a it's
about is there some alternative to to
living these these little tribes that
are constantly war each other or
bringing peace and prosperity by having
you know the Babylonians conquer the
entire world the four corners of the
earth as they as they used to say and
and so here the the God of Israel speaks
to Moses and and even though he's he's
the creator of heaven and earth and he's
the God of everything he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't tell Abraham he
doesn't tell Moses go go out and conquer
the whole world he gives them borders
the first as far as we know the first
borders any God ever gave his people he
says here are your borders and you're
not allowed to cross them you're not
allowed to go trouble the the neighbors
because they have they have their own
land and their own promise in their own
way now this is this is a huge
revolution in political thought but but
at the same time also also in theology
that that there could be a God that
cares about all humanity but what he
wants is is each different each
different nation to you know to have its
own freedom now take that as an example
that's that's something that I think
it's very difficult to to have an
anglo-american conservatism that uh
pollutes that biblical heritage
okay now that that doesn't dictate you
know what you know what you believe on
every subject just because you're
conservative right but you but if you
don't have some kind of if you don't
have a sense that there's something
incredibly important that needs to be
honored and hand handed down in that
tradition then it's going to be really
hard for you to being conservative so
how do you make room that
so I get it so on a on a macro level
you're saying you need though that those
underpinnings on the micro level for the
individual that comes across that maybe
that either isn't religious or or for
gay people or well anyone that's that's
sort of the outsider how can they say
all right well I can fit into this this
conservative idea well in different
different times different periods of
history there were tighter and looser
more inclusive and less inclusive
versions of the traditions that we're
talking about this is I I think there's
an important common very common
misconception about conservatism is that
often people are not conservatives
assume that the traditions are
monolithic that they dictate one answer
on every question you know the the
tradition is this authoritarian thing it
it's always been the same it has you
know it has a catechism and and you you
just have to believe and do whatever
you're told and if you don't then then
you're out I think that's it completely
but it's almost a propagandistic view of
the way traditions actually worked the
way traditions actually work is that
that of course a strong tradition does
does seek to inculcate norms when I say
want to say norms I mean the thing that
it would be best to do were the thing
that would be best to be but being the
the fact that tradition hands down
certain norms first of all there's huge
arguments within the tradition about
what those norms are right I mean the
traditions that themselves are very
often very pluralistic internally and
then even if you're not part of that
pluralism there's there's additional
layers there's the there's there's the
things that that are strongly encouraged
and the things they're slightly
encouraged and those things that are
tolerated and they're things things that
are
are are considered problematic but but
you leave them alone for now and then
the things that the tradition you know
goes after and tries to to say look that
that's really gonna ruin us right
murdering people is a bit - right so so
I I think that the more conservative you
become and the more you study what
conservatism really is as opposed to you
know the cartoon version of it that we
get in in you know most academic courses
on the subject let's say or on
television what when when you study it
of course you'll find things in the past
that you know that that you'll see as as
terrible nobody's pretending that's not
the case but a tradition is something
that is always internal internally
pluralistic it has different levels of
space that it makes for different
different kinds of dissidents and you
know for example the the English
tradition is it's it's often accused of
being anti-catholic and and you'll
notice that its relationship with with
with Judaism is not the same as its
relationship with Catholicism why
because because the the periods that
we're talking about are periods in which
Catholicism was was the official
ideology of a world empire that was
trying to conquer conquer the English
and prevent them from being independent
and I'm not saying everything that was
done in the name of defending against
this what you know was for what was
perfectly well executed but you have to
I think use some common sense a nation
that's facing a world empire that has a
certain religion that is that that
that's its formal ideology well of
course they're not going to treat
Catholics the same way that they're
going to treat other dissidents but I I
think people are always looking to
looking at the past to see Oh gotcha
look they they persecuted this and that
the other thing and if we and and
usually it's true
but they're not looking at the way in
which in which dissidents did in fact
flourish increasingly over the millennia
under these these different different
different kinds of regimes I mean the
fact is we Jews are still here I mean
there was plenty of persecution there's
plenty to complain about but the fact is
that we're still here and and and and
that that that means that there were
times and places throughout the history
of Christianity and Islam where where
the Jews had more or less status more or
less tolerance more or less contribution
in in society and I so I I would say
that with regard to conservatism today
[Music]
we're in any case in a period where what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
salvage what we can
all right I mean I I don't know if it's
going to succeed but as a conservative
the the map that I faced is today is
virtually every major idea or concept or
ideal that was handed down from the past
has been savagely attacked or and and
maybe overthrown in the last few
generations so I'm talking about the
idea of the nation they give the family
the the the ideas of man and woman of
God and scripture of holiness of Honor I
mean you could just keep going and going
I mean anything that that that I think
created the things that are good in our
world today
that that really worked is now being
savaged and and destroyed and I'm you
know I'm looking for allies I'm not
looking looking for enemies I've got a
favorite right here I have enough I mean
the the the people who are and and and
it's it's many the ones who are actively
purposely destroying these things and
the ones who are just going along with
it I mean that that's most of our
culture so
you know III would be real grateful for
a willingness to have conversation with
anybody who's willing to to try to to
work out a contemporary conservatism
that could do some good and that would
be you know as inclusive as possible all
right then so let's take this
conversation into the modern world
there's a couple things happening right
now that's sort of finished well that
you talk about in the book but that that
fit perfectly for this conversation so
let's talk about Trump first people
describe him as a nationalist he talks
about America first as far as I can tell
he doesn't want to nation-build all over
the world and expand American Empire
everywhere that's sort of your kind of
nationalism right yeah it is I I think
on nationalism Trump Trampas is
excellent I mean he's he's not just he's
not just looking for ways you know what
and this is you know whether you think
that he's finding the right ways are
proposing the right ways is his the his
theme is he's looking for ways to try to
to think about America as a nation
rather as rather than as a world empire
we need to come back to that in a second
okay
but with but then he goes and he speaks
in front of the United Nations right and
he says look I'm not just saying that my
job is America first I'm talking all the
nations I'm saying look each of you
you're elected by a certain public or
you represent a certain public and and
your job is to take care of those people
and I I think that's that's exactly the
kind of of nationalism we should be
thinking does that right there show you
how crazy things have gotten at the
academic level because even when he says
that that we should just think about
ourselves first that somehow is thought
of as xenophobic or racist or something
like that and it really anyone if you
really sat in it and thought about it
for a second or maybe if you if you
remove Trump's personality or whatever
it is but if you thought about just what
he's saying that Americans should care
about America first and what happens
with our border first it's sensible
as you said if we get nominees it's
sensible look that people in the United
States are convinced that they have some
kind of uniquely crazy thing going on
because of who Trump is I actually I
think this is actually just not true I
mean if you go just just just go look at
the UK right they don't have Donald
Trump you think that things are any less
crazy in the UK than they are we'll get
to Briggs it no but but it's just look
at a sister democracy within a lot of
ways a very a very similar culture and
the the the elites I'm talking about the
universities the media the a lot of the
the the the career politicians and
bureaucrats there's this layer of people
who are are they're just as crazy
against any kind of indications of of
nationalism and national independence in
the UK as as they are in America so it's
not Trump didn't cause this craziness
Trump is is actually more of an effect
than he is a cause the craziness
predates him the craziness begins with I
mean it has a long history but let's say
roughly the craziness begins roughly in
1989 when the when the Soviet Union
Falls the Berlin Wall Falls and America
which had had spent most of its not not
all but most of its two centuries of
Independence arguing for the virtue of
independent nations right being mostly
on that side of things right when the
when the when the the Americans were
broadcasting their radio broadcasts into
Europe during World War two what were
they were they broadcasting they're
broadcasting you've been conquered by
like the evil empire and we're coming to
free the nations of Europe so that then
they will be able to live independently
that was like we're not coming to make
our little satellite right we're not
coming to be you know a better Empire to
conquer you and rule you right so so
the time it was clear and I think most
people probably don't realize how
incredibly unique that is right that a
country would go halfway across the
world to do that right it's a it's a
it's a very special thing you know and
we can we can talk about but this this
goes back to a religion point when FDR
on the eve of World War two
right this FDR gives is in Jan in
January 1939 he has a State of the Union
address what he can already see that
America is gonna go to war against
against the fascists and maybe the
Communists too and and and he describes
what it is that were what is it we
Americans are fighting for what are we
gonna be fighting for and he says first
of all for our religion and then from
our religion comes our democracy and our
willingness to have comedy among nations
but he says first and foremost religion
in fact he calls the Allied nations he
calls them the god-fearing democracies
right today nobody would say there it
did no nobody would understand that FDR
and and the people then thought they
were fighting for god-fearing countries
against atheists totalitarians nobody
thinks like that anymore but but but
that's what it was all right so so if if
we go back to where does this
willingness to allow other nations their
freedom come from FDR at least knows
that it comes it comes from from
Christianity that comes from Judaism and
Christianity but to go back to to to to
the the current crisis we've got elites
that after 1989 and it doesn't matter if
they call themselves liberal or
conservative I mean almost all of them
Democrats Republicans labor conservative
in the UK and almost all the parties in
Europe went after this utopian dream of
one law to cover the entire Earth a
George HW Bush called it the New World
Order
like if you're nationalists you you hear
this kind of thing it just sends a chill
down yes the bells are all going right
the bells go off what that that's why
the America won the Cold War was to it
was to impose order on the entire planet
now
America's gonna decide I mean that was
that was really kind of a kooky moment
and now that but but Bush is that that
one world ordered order speech I mean he
had a few of them but but the particular
one world order speech and he says
explicitly for a thousand generations
mankind has been struggling to reach
this moment it's like this utopian thing
a thousand generations we've been
struggling to reach this moment but but
but all the previous generations have
failed and now we're gonna succeed what
are we going to succeed it he says we're
going to eliminate the the law of the
jungle and replace it by the rule of law
right it I mean it's it's like this you
know John Lannan stuff like you lead the
entire planet is gonna be this
borderless thing under a single moon
under a single law and we'll all somehow
automatically love each other and right
we won't more with each other and we're
gonna have because the whole common
because the whole past was you know
based on ignorance and darkness and
illusion that you know there was nothing
good back there and I mean didn't
explicitly say that but that that's the
clear implication but it's funny that
it's a very real Marxist idea coming out
it's George a absolutely absolutely
nobody would really think it absolutely
is but that's I mean if you're sometimes
you hear conservatives like me say look
it's all just liberalism right it you
know it doesn't it doesn't matter what
label they put on it because because the
the fact is that that all the elites at
the top of all of these academic
institutions and and and political
parties they they had all these
disagreements among one another but the
right they disagree they thought they
had election campaigns but they but but
they weren't disagreeing about the
fundamentals the fundamental was we
liberals in the West we know how to run
the world we've got the answer like all
you need to do is you know take take the
way America runs and or Germany or
whatever you want and and apply it to
every country in the world to every
nation in the world but if necessary by
force will dictate the rules there's
gonna rule for the whole planet and if
somebody does something wrong then we
start bombing them which it I mean
that's it's simplistic but that's
roughly a description
of an entire generation of American and
and and and and and European political
thought that would be like the
neoconservatives basically right well
they're they're just one strand I mean
you you know you'll notice that the the
the the new conservatives may have been
arguing right for let's say invade
invade Iraq and Afghanistan whereas
liberals in Europe might have been
saying no don't invade Iraq and
Afghanistan so that their substantive
disagreements but what they're not
disagreeing about is that the European
ideal of eliminated all the borders
mmm-hmm right a a the the European Union
founded in 1992 in in in it in its
current form meaning right after the
Berlin Wall fell the the idea we're
gonna take down all the borders we're
not gonna have restrictions on
immigration or the free or trade or
anything that we every everybody's gonna
be free to be part of one thing and
Europe itself you know has no borders
right your your your Europe didn't know
and still doesn't know to this day how
many countries on earth it's going to
expand to embrace and its entire project
of the European elites is creating world
courts and and world economic bodies to
regulate everything on earth and get
everybody on one page doing doing doing
one thing so so there's an argument
between the Europeans and the Americans
should the Americans be invading Iraq
but there's no argument about what the
project is there's no argument about the
idea that we don't actually need
diversity among nations we don't need
independent nations we need one central
thing that's going to govern everything
so is the simplest way to encapsulate
their argument is that's like their I
get to did there's this dystopian idea
or sort of that by freeing everybody or
something that I removed that you know
we'll just ignore thousands of years of
history and we're all gonna love each
other or something like that but with
the more nefarious version of this is
that while one-world government now you
can absolutely control everybody I mean
would you say that's really the heart of
this it's really about control it's
really
everybody right you're exactly right
it's well they say they're freeing
everybody but their idea of freedom is
it is mattei kissed a small example from
you know from being an Orthodox Jew I
think this applies to everybody but but
they have an idea of what human rights
is and they they're sure that their idea
of human rights is true for everybody on
earth never mind the fact that you know
every five or ten years the content of
it actually moves right right but at any
given seeing right that's right but at
any given moment they think that they
know you know what you know what the
absolute you know what reason with a
capital R what it dictates is that the
true set up for rights for everybody on
earth so so as an Orthodox Jew III I
immediately run into problems with this
why because because we have a tradition
going back thousands of years of
circumcising our male children and and
it's it's it's a a central symbol of of
both the of the hardship of joining the
Jewish people and and going into
covenant with God that's our tradition
you don't have to like it or not like it
that's the way do thing we can do things
it's incredibly important to us now now
the the the universal reason people they
come and say well look you're fighting
violating the rights of the child and so
you're not allowed to do that anymore
we're gonna ban it or we have a method
of slaughtering animals for food that
goes back thousands of years coat kosher
slaughter and from our traditional
understanding this is this is a
humanitarian right the the the the the
the Jewish kosher slaughter it it its
aim is to eliminate among other things
to to eliminate things like hunting and
tearing animals apart and doing all
sorts of other horrible things no
there's only certain animals you're
allowed to slaughter and you have to
slaughter them in a certain way which
which
traditionally we thought that's the most
painless way but now the the the the
universal human rights people are you
know in this case universal rights
people they come and say no you you
can't slaughter your way because we know
the answer of you know of the best way
to slaughter an animal and so you're
gonna do it are I mean basically what
they're saying is is you're not allowed
to be a Jew you're not allowed to be a
traditional Jew because we figured out
the answer is we if you got the answers
for everybody and if you want to do it
do to do your traditions then that will
shut you down now that same argument is
true that I just gave forest a toxic UD
ism it's true for every but it's true
for every tradition there's no such
thing as some professors in Germany sit
and figure out the universal human
rights for all time and and then we
impose it on everybody without
oppressing all the other people have
their own traditions of how it's so
interesting to me because as you know I
came from the left and I wasn't
progressive and I saw this and then when
I started waking up to it that's sort of
when people started caring about what I
was thinking but I remember thinking
that even when the gay rights movement
was happening in America that there was
this very odd thing that if you didn't
get to exactly where they were on gay
rights or gay marriage that day they got
there that you were automatically a
bigot and it's like what a crazy way of
viewing the world because Barack Obama
who nobody in their right mind would
think his anti-gay he ran against gay
marriage he was not for gay marriage the
first time he went around so history if
these people win the long game history
will be not too kind to Barack Obama and
I guess we're gonna have to take down
his library which is being constructed
right now I think they're gonna take
that down because he was against the
human rights that are gonna be very
obvious to them this is about twenty
thirty years this is such this is such
an important point I mean the the the
only way that you can keep the only way
that you can preserve a certain way of
doing things or a certain idea is
through through traditions that passed
down an attitude of sacredness and
giving honor to to that way of doing
things and you know of course nothing
you
it's permanent everything changes a
little bit from generation to generation
but but we see in you know if I look at
looking at the the the the Jews or in
India or or or or in China we can see we
see that there are some things that can
actually be handed down over thousands
of years it it's possible but this idea
that our reason is just gonna figure out
the right thing and never mind the past
that's just all that's doing is creating
a permanent revolution mm-hmm where
every single generation it means even
every 10 years
it already devours and rejects and
destroys the thing that it created just
a few moments ago mm-hmm all right so
there there are some people who you know
who who in theory they find that
attractive they I mean they're these
young people usually right find that
very attractive like everything before
us was awful and you know in it it's
it's part of being apparently part of
being human is that a lot of adolescents
feel during their adolescence that
really nothing is important other than
the fact that I'm free and I decide to
do what I want and you know it it's not
true of all adolescents but it's true of
a lot of adolescents it's a very very
common thing and and and and it's part
of being human
but but when you're grown up you have to
take responsibility for questions like
is is my nation is my religion are my
traditions actually good if I believe
that they're good if I believe they're
contributing good to the world then
there are things I need to do in order
to hand them down it's not a few things
it's a lot of things
Uman beings if they're not if if if they
don't work really hard to maintain the
the the honoring of the traditions the
traditions get thrown out of the window
and you're gonna have nothing left now
let's take something like
free speech because I know you talk
about it a lot and free speech is people
think about free speech as though I mean
it's the standard thing to say is it
it's a right it's a human right it's in
the Constitution it's a unit but people
rarely way too rarely focus on the fact
that the actual implementation of a
regime of free speech is a tradition
mm-hmm
it's a tradition if if you need to work
hard to raise your children to not tell
the other one to shut up
you need to train them over years it
makes you angry that your brother is
saying that that your sister saying that
makes you angry I mean that they're
constantly ready to go to war over right
that's the way kids are and you have to
train them and work on them and work on
them to civilize them allow the other
one to speak I know that it's making you
angry but allow them to speak let them
talk then you'll get your turn
now that that little family vignette
it's actually true of the of the entire
civilization the fact that that you can
have a you know a country room most
people are willing to allow someone else
to say what they think even though they
disagree that's an incredibly difficult
tradition to inculcate so to raise
people to do that that's a fight that
you have to refight in in in the
education of the entire country in every
generation it's you there's no point in
asserting it because it's reasonable
it's not about whether it's reasonable
it's about what what are you willing to
do to make these traditions channel
people in such a way that guess what
they're not free someone says something
you don't like
then you're not free to just start start
cursing them out like people do on
Twitter you're not free to do that
because self restraint self constraint
is the only way that freedom of speech
is going to exist in your country that
means that we need to focus on on the
constraints part on how do you get
people to not do whatever they want
that's the only way that free speech can
continue to exist it's so that the even
even the things that seem to be
like the most valuable freedoms are they
exist because they are anglo-american
traditions and if you're running a
revolution where you're overthrowing one
tradition after another after another
nothing is going to be left of the
things that we value including the
freedoms so all right so that being said
and that's that could have been the
ending right there because that's how
you cap a show right but if everything
you said is true right there
then how concerned are you for the
future because it does seem that the
forces that you are fighting against in
this book are getting stronger
yeah it's it it's very frightening it on
the free speech thing you know a
generation ago I was at university and I
started the the Prince natori it's the
it was the the Pro Reagan publication on
the University campus and of course lots
of people didn't like it conservative
where I'm minority and people call me
names people you know there's all sorts
of nastiness but nobody ever thought it
was illegitimate it's a different era I
mean we had friends who were liberals
with friends were progressive nobody
thought that our publication that our
pro Reagan's our conservative
publication that it was illegitimate
yeah right they didn't think no you're
not allowed to say that and this is
where someone like Ben Shapiro who often
is just saying the things that Reagan
said that we're going over and [ __ ] and
today people are there's lots of things
so in those days I would just say
whatever I you know whatever I thought I
would write whatever I wanted I that's
how I grew up but I tell my children you
know and I'm ashamed of this but but
it's true I tell my children now look
there's things you believe that you're
you're not allowed to say anymore
and I wish it weren't like that I'd like
to see it change but right now there's
no point in like in you know throwing
away your your your your capacity to
earn a living and to do good on all
sorts of fronts because you insist on
just saying whatever you want to say I
can't stand it but that's that's the
reality is that is that
the the the the the the zone for four
for freedom of speech is is rapidly
rapidly closing it's getting narrower
and narrower and and and that's just one
example of the things that we've lost
I'm I think it's a very it's a very
frightening period but let me just say
one positive thing because I mean look I
can easily plot a trajectory where where
where America doesn't make it through
this but look let me look at the other
possibility this is also a a moment of
great opportunity because it's there's a
a tradition among diplomats that you you
you read sometimes in in history books
that kind of a legend that the world is
like an ice cap the political world is
like an ice cap and every every once in
a while it it unfreezes and it breaks up
and it rearranges itself so like every
50 years or every 75 every hundred years
and we really do seem to be in a period
like that where where all the bets
really are off and that will you know
hopefully draw to the front creative
strong people who have of something
important to offer to the refreezing the
re re construction of of the world
that's coming this reconstruction you
know it it it can be something
absolutely horrendous and I don't we
shouldn't kid ourselves we're really
moving in a bad direction but the reason
that I find the nationalist movements
encouraging in in American the UK in
other countries is not because it's not
because you know I I support everything
that every one of these people say or do
I actually have absolutely no idea what
most of them you know are going to do
and a lot of them are new to politics
and we don't actually know
they're going to do but but what I but I
do see the opportunity I don't I don't
know if it's going to turn out well but
I do see clearly the opportunity when
when right because the national
movements movements could take a turn
for the worse right they could start to
to things that are about race and they
have no national anthem of those times
they they certainly could and and and
that is actually one of the things that
that that i say when i when i go around
give it a giving talks is i i've noticed
that many conservatives dismiss the the
racist right they i mean they have a a
lot of conservatives they look that they
they're looking at you know how strong
is the Nazi Party or the KKK and and and
and they are they're trivial I mean
they're absolutely trivial and it's
completely unfair to associate
conservatism with that and and and so
it's reasonable in the sense that they
dismiss it but but looking at the level
of at the level of ideas of who's who's
thinking who's trying to actually come
up with a worldview that could a few
years from now become something
important I think it's a mistake to to
dismiss the far right not that I'm not
that I'm sympathetic to them but the the
quality of the of the the arguments the
the work that's being done by people to
justify a kind of a neo-darwinian kind
of racism like a white a white identity
politics they're actually doing quite a
bit of work to get this idea into shape
now I I detest it right I I hope it's
soundly defeated but it's really quite
attractive to lots of people in 20s in
their 30s who are looking at you know
the the old liberal order and saying oh
my gosh will that that doesn't work so
so where do we go and it means that yeah
we have those of us who are inclined to
a national
Servat ISM that is that has nothing to
do with race that that you know those of
us who think the color of your skin
really should make you know absolutely
zero difference in the way that we order
society there's so many important
important issues why the color of your
skin so those of us who are inclined to
a national conservatism which will
believe in in the nation and its
heritage but have no interest in you
know in the genetic population that you
know that you supposedly came from we
have a lot of work to do to create
something that's gonna be sufficiently
powerful I'm talking an idea that's
sufficiently coherent and powerful and
attractive so that it will actually have
be able to be politically effective it
before these other guys fight the forces
right before before these other guys you
know before they win I mean right now
they're not winning but ten years from
now 20 years from I wouldn't I think all
bets are off we don't know where this is
going and so so there is there are
dangers but there's an opportunity to
create a a much more traditionalist
conservative a decent moderate common
sense traditionalist conservatism which
will be national which will be
nationalist which will will will believe
in the traditions of nations and and and
seek to maintain their independence
there's a space to do that and it's
exciting to be able to do that because
that space hasn't existed you know for
the last generation it was you know no
one wanted to hear it well that's a
conservative space that a good
old-fashioned liberal could could be
okay with you know we've barely
scratched the surface here but we got a
rapper now so I we should we should
definitely do this again okay I love to
can I get you back here to the United
States and do this again
Israel will do it in Jerusalem by you a
stake next to the old city walls if you
come to Jerusalem done I'm done all
right for more on your arm follow him on
Twitter why hezonia
[Music]